[музика]
na Po Per
наваі моя ма
друзі Доброго дня Вітаю вас і знову ми
тут Ми стоїмо кожен раз на майданчиках
аби захищати Нашу З вами державу
захищати мову захищати наших волонтерів
військових ця тенденція не зупиняється
Але добре що є ми з вами люди які не
байдужі які витрачають свій час сили аби
припинити це політичне і правове
свавілля
сьогодні тут військові сьогодні тут
волонтери сьогодні тут депутати
Київської міської ради сьогодні тут
депутати Верховної Ради сьогодні тут
прості небайдужі люди солідарна море
молодь справа громад і ті хто працюють
на заводі кузіна рибальського і ви
знаєте основна наша мета
зупинити правове свавілля ми не дамо
нищити Нашу З вами державу ви бачите на
наших плакатах написано чіткі меседжі і
ці меседж Ми хотіли би аби Зеленський
прочитав почув або йому просто розказали
тому що
єдине чого боїться влада це волі і гніву
народу тому ми чітко кажемо що Патріот
не є ворогом ми Захистимо тих хто
захищав нашу державу і захищає
досі
сьогодні Зеленський чітко
показує зі своїми
стовідсотковими прокурорами
совідсотковими слідчими з усіма тими
кому він дзвонить і просить шити справи
зеленими нитками він тільки показує що в
Україні не настала епоха
не настав кінець епохи бідності а настав
кінець демократії але ви знаєте ми з
вами і є та рушійна
сила яка може це
зупинити кожен пост у Фейсбуці і кожен
раз коли ви приходите сюди Ви показуєте
свою небайдужість і ми з вами точно
переможемо ми тут проти
кривосуддя люди прийшли і на їх плакатах
написано ми єдині будуємо кораблі для
МВС України дайте працювати але кожен
раз ми виходимо Ми змушені виходити і
захищати кожен раз різні речі але ви
знаєте що мені здається що Зеленський
робить єдине це втілює план Кремля
сьогодні в Україні тому що тільки Кремлю
і Росії буде цікаво дискредитувати нашу
з вами державу наших з вами волонтерів
нашу наших з вами військовіх і тих хто
боронив Нашу З вами незалежність
починаючи з
Майдану і тому я зараз хотіла би надати
слово
людині яка точно знає що таке
державність що таке
українськість Що таке наша незалежна
Віра що таке політичні
протистояння тому запрошую до слова
Ростислава Павленка депутата Верховної
Ради Слава
українігела друзі дуже дякую всім хто
сьогодні прийшов на жаль доводиться і
такі дні проводити тут під судом для
того щоби показати всім показати
зеленсько показати його прислужникам що
Україна своїх не кидає Зеленський
випрошувати у Путіна зустрічі кидаючи за
грати бойових генералів і виробничників
які здатні постачати цим генералам зброю
яка здатна зупиняти Путіна дуже великим
розчаруванням для Путіна і його
подільників було те наскільки швидко
згузня на рибальському змогла поставити
бойові караблі морському флоту України і
всі пам'ятаємо що було після захоплення
Криму коли флот фактично було знищено і
Україна її морські рубежі опинилися
беззахисною після того
кузнянорбальському була спроможена
поставити в стрі кораблі які могли
давати е відбір російському агресору в
Чорному і Азовському морях це Путіну не
подобається і ми бачимо що ті хто був
здатен ці кораблі виробляти і ті хто міг
цим кораблям дати правильне бойове
застосування зараз не нагороджені зараз
не в пошані а на жаль під судом ми
будемо робити все щоби виправити це
кривосуддя ми будемо робити все щоби
справедливість було відновлено А що
треба для цього для те для цього треба
щоби і Зеленський і судді і прокурори і
вся решта знали що всі їх Викрутаси ні
до чого не призведуть ми тут збиралися
29 липня пам'ятаєте Я думаю що Практично
всі тут були пам'ятаєте знаєте що було в
суді якщо суд поважає це високе звання
Обвинувачення не притрималось би і
кількох не то що годин і кількох хвилин
воно шите як було сказано зеленими
нитками там слово суперечить слово там
неясно взагалі будь-яка обставина яка
могла би складати склад злочину тому
пішли на підлі трюки прокурори не
з'явились Ми з колегами поїхала до
генеральної прокурорки вона каже що вона
нічого не знала буде вестися
розслідування по інших справах прокурор
раптом з'явились але не з'явилися
обвинувачування тому ми застерігаємо
щоби сьогодні не було трюків Ми з
колегами народними депутатами будемо на
засіданні для того щоби засвідчити щоби
там все було принаймні відповідно до
закону будемо вас інформувати що
відбувається але головне щоби і судді і
прокурори і найголовніше зеленськийого
кампанія пам'ятали і знали що є контроль
і є небайдужі люди які не дадуть їм
спуску а по тому що відбувалося 29го
числа захист буде подавати до
Європейського Суду з прав людини тому що
там є абсолютно чіткий склад тортур
знущання бо ставити такий обсяг застави
який
виставлено і генералам і виробничнику
шандрі він не має ніякого стосунку Ні до
правосуддя ні до здорового глузду тому
що тримати штучно людей за гратами це є
тортури і всім хто був причетний до цих
неправомірних рішень ще доведеться
відповідати тому боротьба попереду Всім
удачі і Слава
Україні Слава і знаєте меседж який
Хотілось би щоб почули
всі який кожен раз ми повторюємо і
давайте друзі разом покажемо Наскільки
нам це болить Патріот не ворог Патріот
не ворог Патріот не ворог Патріот не
ворог Патріот не ворог Патріот не ворог
Патріот не горог Патріот не Горо Патріот
не Горо Патріот не Горо Патріот не Горо
біля мене зараз стоїть людина яка на
своїй власній шкірі відчула те наскільки
ганебна на сьогоднішній день Зелена
Влада наскільки вони використовують
методи Януковича методу Росії і
залякуване тих хто боровся на Майдані за
наших тому я передаю слово Тетяні
чорновал Дякую всім що прийшли
підтримати
шандру директора заводу
кузняно-рибальському йому це насправді
дуже потрібно і навіть якщо він нас не
чує йому Передають що зібралися люди що
його підтримують і Повірте в його
ситуацію це дуже-дуже важливо а Звичайно
тут прийшли і працівники заводу кузня на
рибальському Я хочу вам сказати що
вашого заводу це не справа проти вашого
директора це взагалі справа проти
українського захисту і оборони це
насправді надзвичайно глобальна справа і
навіть не в тому тут так би мовити доказ
того що по цій справі йде не тільки
директор вашого заводу йдуть також
посадовці Міноборони які просто
виконували свою роботу підписували ті
документи які які би мусили підписувати
робили ті справи які би мусили би робити
якби вони це не робили їх би за це треба
було судити та але справа навіть не в
тому да що цілий перелік і посадовців
екс екс-посадовців Міністерства оборони
і директор вашого заводу Справа в тому
що насправді це ціла концепція яка
реалізується в Україні проти захисту
проти оборнодатно
Тому що хочу подякувати зокрема
працівникам заводу за те що вони робили
ці катера а хочу зауважити що от ну
приклад да яка це ганебна і абсурдна
справа Тобто ви робили катера за ціною
там 5 млн доларів штуку в той же час до
нас наприклад надійшли американські
катера isн подібного типу безкоштовно
але ми за них теж заплатили 5 млн
доларів за штумку Ну от безкоштовно
стільки коштувала тому що треба було ще
відремонтувати треба було техогляд
зробити треба транспортування цих
катерів ну тобто безкоштовні катери і
ваші катери коштували однаково про що це
значить це значить що завод працював
навіть попри свою рентабельність не на
рентабельність він працював на країну в
якій ійде війна яку треба захищати я
дякую вам що ви вкладали свої всі
зусилля і ви робили ці катери адже
зроблено це і гурза і Кентавр ці катери
несуть службу знов таки навіть коли
відбулася керщенська криза ми могли всі
українці мо могли зауважити про те що
ваші катира якісне ви згадайте ту
ситуацію яка тоді була в кершенській
протоці як російський Чорноморський флот
який переважав в кількості отої от
конвої українських катерів який йшов в
Азовське море почав таранити наші
кораблі буксир протаранили а катери
гюрза протаранити не змогли натомість
кораблі російсько-чорноморського флоту
врізались між собою тараняч ваші катери
тобто дякую вам що ви зробили маневрені
бойові одиниці які навіть в таких умовах
нерівного бою коли в принципі вони не
могли й зброю застосовувати бо тоді це
би означало би повну ліквідацію кораблів
і складу і військових і екіпажу тому що
Зрозуміло в якій вони тоді опинилися
ситуацію але на в тій ситуації вони
фактично тактично виграли оцей Морський
бій тому що російські катери один одному
завдали пошкодженні дуже серйозні До
речі пошкодження так от ви молодці Ви
все це робили тепер ми бачимо ситуація
така якщо в комплексі знову таки
характеризувати те що відбувається ми
зараз можемо прочитати новини що ваш
завод так би мовити проти нього йде
боротьба фінансування тих проектів які
були заплановані в попередні роки
попередньої Влади не відбувається та
директора саджають завод зупиняється
натомість можемо прочитати в новинах що
за 600 млн доларів 600 млн доларів
закуповуються американські катари знов
таки схожі Можливо вони чимось кращі
тому що ну зрештою американські там в
них дуже
велика зновутаки практика виробництво
Одна справа яки забод працює на на
Катара там багато десятків років інша
інша справа коли він тільки почав
відновлюватися по суті в 14-му році з
початку бойових дій Да але чомусь вони
до речі і гірші а особливо гірші вони в
ціні тому що викидати бюджетні гроші в
країні в яких не фінансуються оборонні
програми на катери які в принципі не
такто ну можуть захистити Україну від
від всіх проблем які в нас виникають з
Російської Федерації вони захистять вже
катери від літаків Які би гарні
американські катери не були від літаків
вони не захистять від ракет вони не
захистять від піхоти і танків вони не
захистять а на них викидаються два
річних оборотних бюджета для чого А я
вам скажу для чого Тому що справа це в
тому що треба якимось маневром зупиняти
розвиток українського озброєння захисту
оборони просто так все зупинити
неможливо це ж в нас же є ВНО
громадянське суспільство яке почне
кричати знов таки захід почне кричати що
це в Україні війна а Україна ні копійки
не дає наборнузнатність От і придумана
така специфіка А давайте всі гроші
зільємо тут і захід буде мовчати бо це ж
їхні катерин тут же активне громадянське
суспільство що вони можу сказати в
Америці ж купують правда але натомість
ми ні копійки не залишимо для наших для
наших оборонних знодів для нашого
озброєння для того озброєння яке
найбільш нам актуальне зокрема ракетного
озброєння от така от річ насправді
стратегічно дуже потрібна на Кремлю
зараз відбувається і ваш завод якраз
кузня на рибальському зараз опинився в
Епіцентрі зновутаки всіх маніпуляцій да
Коли використовують різні методи щоб
знищувати знову таки українське
виробництво знову таки справа йде не
тільки про ваш завод всім іншим заводом
оббородного сектору що державного що
приватного дається сигнал не працюйте
вас посадять а якщо вам надійшли гроші
гроші краще нічого не виробляйте бо за
вироблений продукт вас посадять а якщо
не виробити Ну якось ще викнути у вас же
гроші є хабарі нас дасте нинішня Влада
Зелена дуже патка на хабарі Подивіться
як вони дороги в нас будують Да з
відкатами 50%. тому ситуація
відбувається зараз така тому те що ви
тут зібралися і як підтримати свого
директора але тут набагато важливіша
проблема да ви зараз фактично зараз
стоїте тому що треба підтримувати
український захист і оборону Дякую знов
таки тим хто тут зібрався які не заводу
Лені куз на рибальському які знов таки
розуміють цю всю складність проблеми Бо
знов таки це не атака проти опозиції це
не Атака проти заводу не Атака проти
директора не Атака проти Генерала
Павленка Який теж іде в цій справі А це
взагалі Атака проти нашого захисту і
нашої оборони тому давайте боротися це
наша боротьба і хай нас тут не тисячі
але Повірте ми свою справу тут робимо і
насправді тих людей які зараз Т ви
зібралися нас уже все сила насправді це
сила таки ми вже кроками ми впливаємо
насправді ситуацію повіідне Ми впливаємо
Я звичайно не можу прогнозувати Який
сьогодні буде суд ми бачили що було в
Генерала Павленка коли прокурори просто
не з'явилися але це означає що навіть
судді не хочуть виносити такі ганебні
рішення тому що вже дбр і венедиктова
Генпрокуратура просто так би мовити
рятували ситуацію ну свого точки зору да
вони розуміли що суд очевидно випустить
Генерала павловського на волю тому що Ну
немає ніяких Ну взагалі Ну не ніяких
фактів його утримувати під вартою та і
зробили таку просто диверсію
що прокурори не з'явилися подивимося що
буде сьогодні що зновутаки переможе
здоровий глуз в цій країні чи оця от
Зелена дурість да це інакше просто
просто не назвеш але те що ми тут
зібралися Повірте знов таки ми своє
робимо капля камінь точе ми виграємо
тому що ще раз повторю вам і це дуже
важливо зрозумієте капітуляція ніколи не
переможе супрово апріорі неми переможе
ми ми переможемо Да ми переможемо
Можливо ми багато пройдемо заради того
мож чимось пожертвуємо і своїм заради
цього але ми переможемо А це в принципі
головне бо за нами держава Україна Слава
Україні Героям
слава дуже знаєте чітко зазначила Тетяна
про те що ми
переможемо на початку ми говорили про те
що ми вже як така потужна сила як Міцний
горішок який продовжує боронити нашу
державу на різних секторах ви знаєте для
нас
насправді
дуже і
боляче і
дуже поруч історія про те що наших
знаєте
ще там батьків дідусів намагалася якось
радянською владою приглушити приглушити
свободу слова
приглушити взагалі цю
свободу намагалась якось знецінити
державність нашу Україну в цілому але
Майдан він чітко показав що країна
Україна хоче жити саме в європейській
державі де Існують правила норми права
людини свобода слова і своя власна
українськість державність яку ніхто і
ніяк не може
знищити мої друзі стояли так само на
Майдані Я тоді стояла десь в Дніпрі і по
всій країні люди намагались сказати
чітке ні російському тоталітарному
режиму але обманувши нас
всіх Зеленський і його банда скажемо так
тому що по-іншому назвати людей які
відверто брешуть та кридуть на не можна
намагаються в нас за волосся взяти і
затягнути назад під вплив Російської
держави нашого агресора
окупанта того хто забрав багато життів
наших
побратимів того хто ганебно на
інформаційному фронті намагається
поплюжити наших військових наших
волонтерів ви напевно бачили всі ці
відос ки і ви знаєте дуже схожий
метод включаєш
1+1 який не можна назвати каналом
інформаційним а там те ж саме ті ж самі
відосики які
поплюжать політичну опозицію поплюжать
військових волонтерів і намагаються
розхвалити теперішню владу Чи це є
демократія Я думаю що ні г + г г + г От
бачить люди кажуть
і ви
знаєте політичні репресії демократичні
держави
це сьогоднішній наш з вами
виклик який ми точно подолаємо виклик
який зможе нас просунути ще далі І ніхто
не зможе в цьому нас зупинити тому ми
чітко кажемо ні політичним репресіям ні
політичним репресіям ні політичним
репресіям ні політичним репресіям ні
репресіям
ні політичним
репресіям ні політичним
[музика]
репресія Слава Україні
герої друзі Ми
продовжуємо засідання вже
почалося і ми будемо як мога швидше
доповідати вам розповідати про ситуацію
всередині ви знаєте ще раз повторюся що
бути тут серед волонтерів і активістів
тих хто боронив нашу державу - це велика
честь Тому що тут відчувається дух
українськості єдності і боротьби
боротьби яка триває споконвіків але
точно боротьби за нашу з вами державу і
це є шаною і гордістю Я хотіла би до
слова запросити людину яка не з слів не
з книжок не з відосиків
а особисто фізично і до сьогодні
захищає і допомагає нашим військовим Це
військовий волонтер і справжній
українець Гліб Бабич
вітаємо будь-яка Влада пройде свідів яка
тяготіє до
диктатури завжди діє за стандартною
схемою своїм
все решті
закону так діяв юнуков
який встиг частину країни розпихати по
кишеням і трохи не знищив українську
державність що з ним сталося і де він
зараз ми знаємо але нинішня Влада нач
начолі з найвпливовішим політиком
всесвіту Зеленським пішла ще дальше тому
що вони рівно гарантують своїм і чужим
беззаконня тільки для своїх беззаконня
це можливість
творити будь-який безлад будь-які схеми
будь-які порушення закону їм за За це
нічого не буде а Для решти тобто для нас
беззаконня
це
можливість плювати на закон і робити з
нами як Вони думають все що вони
захочуть Це почалося ще в 19 році це
розвилося у перший дзвіночок справа
генерала марченка і його групи Так звана
справа
бронежилетів яка як і зараз була
злеплена як с сьогодні вже сказали і
зшита зеленими нитками вона розвалилася
давно Алі але люди які по цій справі
знаходяться под слідством і досі
знаходяться под слідством і негласно їм
кажеть ви будете знаходитися под
слідством стільки скільки ми захочемо
Потім були справи патріотів волонтерів
військових потім була справа Шеремета і
зараз це продовжується але і зараз вони
виходять на новий рівень зараз е щоб
відволекти увагу суспільство від того що
вони майже вбили
держзамовлення по оборонці
вони вирішили одним пострілом вбити двох
зайців Минулого тижня ми були тут
коли мала бути апеляція бойового
Генерала павловського як представника за
замовника
держави по цьому заказу Ну ви знаєте що
навіть прокурори збіжали бо вони
вважають що людина яка яку кинули
заграти не має права на
апеляцію теж відбувається сьогодні
сьогодні голови підприємства
кузнянарибальського шандра має отримати
право на своє на свою апеляцію і ми
побачимо що буде але що відбувається
попри те що зараз оборонний заказ заказ
завалений Вони намагаються одним
пострілом двох зайцв як я сказав вбити
по-перше паралізувати всіх чиновників
Міноборони щоб вони дивились на це і
розуміли вони не мають приймати ніяких
рішень вони не мають брати на себе ніяку
відповідальність бо можуть опинитися за
градами вони посадили шандру вони
посадили посадовців
куздіна-рибальського єдиного завода який
судньобудівного який залишився я вам
нагадаю
що пару місяців назад остаточно знищен
ще один завод який можна було відновити
подборонні заказ ще це Чорноморський
судобдіний завод і знищивав пан
Новинський тот самий Олігарх який
настільки віддалений вже від влади що
входить до адміністрації президента як
до себе додому і зараз Вони намагаються
знищити і останнє предприємство яке може
надати нашому флоту кораблі якщо
подивитися у справу вона Смішна вона
ганебна і будь-який спеціаліст її возьме
до рук і вона
розсиплетьсятому що я казав вже навіть
господарської справи там нема це
знущання Це просто людей кинули заграти
під фантастичний залог сумарний майже в
2 млрди за те що вони чітко виконували
свої службові обов'язки селю надати
міністерству оборони боєздатні суда
розбиратися що як і що мого краще можна
але не можна щоби щоб люди опинилися за
гратами до всякого експертного
розбору цієї ситуації
тому я як громадянин України дуже
здивований тим і обурений що
відбувається з Законом з судом судовою
системою і з правами громадян у моїй
країні я дуже здивований як військовий і
обурений тим що заблокований оборонний
заказ що демотивована армія що робиться
все на те щоби ми не могли вчинити о
я здивований величезною кількістю речей
що відбувається в нашії державі і тому
саме з цього ганебного
судилища я хочу запитати владу чий план
ви виконуєте Це точно не є планом по
захисту України і ми дочекаємося поки ми
будемо стояти тут под апеляційним судом
і дивитися щоб вам не
дали права вийти на свободу по ваших
справах по которых ви
будете у суді по довічних справах на які
ви вже наробили Ми примусимо цю державу
стати знову державою Слава
Україні
Слава
[музика]
батькігою метою є це впровадження усіх
наративів Кремля у нас в країні
дискредитація наших волонтерів
військових і всіх тих хто боронить Нашу
З вами
незалежність Я хотіла би нагадати вам
що ми разом з вами є ті хто може це
зупинити і якщо не не будемо ми стояти
тут сьогодні то завтра можуть прийти до
нас і відкрити будь-яку справу з
будь-яком мотивом але він точно буде тим
мотивом який попросить
Банкова і тут у
справі нема жодного
політичного
продовження яки би захищав нас а є
тільки
юридична юридичне свавілі є тільки
відсутність аргументів відсутність
доказів відсутність будь-якого правового
підгрунття і ми розуміємо що все це
можна зламати тільки будучи разом тільки
маючи чітку позицію тільки говорячи
голосно про це і я хотіла би запросити
до слова людину яка не на словах знає як
давати російським окупантам по зубах
депутат Київської міської ради і учасник
українсько-російської війни Олександр
погребицький
Слава нації
вага
сьогодні на сьогоднішньому судовому
засіданні розглядають
справу по пану шандрі директору кузні на
рибальському минулий
четвер ми теж були тут біля апеляційного
суду там де мали розглядати справу по
генералу павловському
в 2019
році ми були під печерським судом де
розглядалась справа
генерал-майора
марченка також за останні два роки після
приходу зеленої влади
розглядалась справа генерала Мельника
стосовно ремонту наших танків так само
розглядалась справа генерала
Шевчука розглядає зараз
справа генерала
Воробйова і інших
генералів ці суди
це не суди про
прізвища і це не суди про звання
це суди про відновлення новітнього
Українського
війська
це суди
проти
того за що українське суспільство
боролось починаючи з 14го
року за сильну
армію за захищену армію бронежилетами
яких взагалі в Збройних Силах не було я
пам'ятаю підрозділ 95ї бригади в якій на
початок війни було чотири бронежилети
0, класу
це справи проти того що ми відновлювали
свою військову
техніку це справи проти того що ми
змінювали харчування наших
військовослужбовців щоб вони харчувались
насікелями про які ми чули і бачили не
один раз і в соціальних мережах і в
новинах а якісним харчуванням як люди
яких поважає їх
суспільство це
справи проти відновлення
військово-морського флоту
України який вийшов з Криму майже Ні
зчим і це справи Не про конкретних людей
це справи проти нас з вами проти тих
кому не
байдуже як вдягнена нагодована і
захищена наша
армія
Вони намагаються показати всьому іншому
суспільства що поважати свої збройні
сили
своїх військових
очільників годувати будувати в Збройних
Силах це
погано натомість провалювати державне
оборонне
замовлення загравати і прирікатись з
нашими
союзниками шантажувати їх союзництвом з
таєм і таким іншим це добре скажіть будь
ласка
Хіба те що робить зараз Зеленський це
правда про українське
суспільство це абсолютна
брехня Це абсолютна брехня з якої пан
Зеленський починав свою виборчу
кампанію і він продовжує намагається
погрузити цю брехню все українське
суспільство він намагається переконати
суспільство в тому що закривати
українські виробництва які
виробляють техніку і кораблі для наших
збройних сил Це добре а очільники цих
підприємств які знаходили ресурси давали
робочі місця і допомагали збройним силам
це злочинці Скажіть мені будь ласка чи
нормальне суспільство може повірити в цю
брехню Я переконаний що ніхто крім нас з
вами не
захистить наше українське військо наше
українське виробництво і наш український
вибір які ми зробили в
2014 році Це вибір сильних збройних сил
Це вибір напрямку в Європейський союз це
вибір в НАТО тільки ми з вами готові
захистити цей вибір це справа в якій
намагаються якимось чином зачепити
лідера політичної сили який не на словах
А на справі за останніх ть років
довіру
що політика в Україні - це не
відосики політика в Україні - це
кропітка і серйозна справа цілодобово і
тільки з таким підходом роботи можливо
досягати європейської асоціації з
Європейським Союзом реформованих
збройних сил успіхів на фронті
відвоювання дхтретин території
України
децентралізації розвитку місцевих громад
і так далі І так далі підвищення
економічного розвитку країни інвестиції
іноземні які бу збільшувались в Україні
з кожним роком на на відміну від того що
відбувається
зараз і на останок Я б хотів би
сказати той хто віднімає кіхті своїх
левів буде від Дани на життя собаками
ворога Слава Україні
Ром
[сміх]
Слава е
[музика]
Зеленський нищить Нашу З вами державу з
різних
фронтів і біля мене стоїть людина яка
точно знає як діє інформаційна гнила
проросійська
Пропаганда те як нас намагаються через
відосіки які До речі пропагує пан
Зеленський якраз такими меседжами Які
розмивають кордони Какая разница для для
нього найкращий мотив а для нас це
вільна незалежна Соборна Україна тому
передаю слово Сергію торано
Слава Україні геро
Слава 14
15-16 роках Україна переживала найважчий
період своєї новітньої історії тоді
здавалося що Україна може не вистояти
тому що зі сходу наступала російська
армія а армії яка була здатна
протистояти Росії тоді ще не було вони
тільки формувалися бо всі попередні
влади всі передні влади займалися
руйнуванням армії вони перетворювали
правоохоронців на свій служат політичних
виконавців але вони не турбувалися про
армію вони не думали що завтра можливо
доведеться захищати Батьківщину і коли
армія насувалася а наші західні партнери
четали в Україні знайшлися люди які
могли дати відсіч Росії і російській
армії це безумовно наші добровольці які
пішли на фронт а це також ті люди які
всередини в тилу створювали українську
армію тому що тоді на заході чекали що
буде в Україні вони чекали чи зможе
Україна протистояти чи зможе Україна
вистояти але жоден жоден західний завод
не постачав тоді в Україну
озброї жодна країна не взялася
сміливості протистояти Росію Вони чекали
що буде в Україні чи здатна буде
українська армія повстати і забезпечити
себе озброєння без допомоги заходу і
тоді теж знайшлися в тилу наші мужні
воїни тилу які змогли створювати
українське озброєння на українських
заводах не чекаючи те чи допоможе нас
хтось ці люди мають зараз бути в почеті
їх має зараз держава винагороджувати ми
маємо зараз ними пишатися А ми зараз
вимушені їх захищати зокрема В цьому
залі суду коли нова влада яка нічого не
зробила для захисту батьківщини починає
судити тих завдяки кому вони стали
владою ця нова влада не спроможна
закичить на Батьківщину тому що є
естьсть немає такої разници ця нова
влада не створює українську армію ця
нова влада не тотурбоється про
військовослужбовців все що ми бачимо від
нової влади - це чергові відосиіки
зашквари скандали які нічим не
завершуються А що думають наші
правоохоронці може вони займаються
владою може вони займаються тими
скандала І щодня Ми чуємо з телебачення
з інтернету ні за останні два роки
правоохоронці не порушили жодної справи
проти тих хто близький до президента
Зеленського жодної справи Не було
порушено проти тих що кожного дня
паплюжить Українську державу хто зливає
українські інтереси хто зав'яз корупції
вся правоохоронна система за останні два
роки працює винятково на ти проти тих
хто хто проти цієї влади хто йде
опозицію проти ветеранів проти
волонтерів проти тих хто захищав
Українську державу які будуть захищати
свою Батьківщину і будуть захищати тих
хто готовий захищати Батьківщину Влада
помиляється тому те зараз що тут
відбувається тут це не відбувається суд
проти наших героїв це відбувається суд
проти влади перший є раунд тільки просто
Влада про це не знає кожна її ляп кожни
її провал це теж буде частиною майбутніх
кримінальних справ тому ми тут сьогодні
з вами пишемо матеріали справи проти
президента Зеленського і його оточення
яке надумало що воно має право судити
героїв а замість того щоби воювати з
Росією воно прагне побачити в очах
Путіна мир ми йому цього не дамо і тому
що тут є небайдужі люди такі які вони
завжди були в Україні і ми з вами знаємо
що справжні Герої - це ті які воюють а
не ті які судять героїв Слава Україні
Героям
слава друзі дуже важливо зараз
підтримати нашого побратима тому шадрі
волю шандрі волю шадрі волю шадрі волю
шандрі волю шандрі волю шандрі волю
шандрі волю шанрі волю шандрі волю
шандрі
[сміх]
[музика]
волю
[оплески]
[музика]
[сміх]
Я смотрю есть или нет
Майдан мыранены в серд но
всётаки
[музика]
танєніз в на і пісню співаєще тішить мій
зух я доторіс щоб через цірщ тілоуючи
звішиіду
Тиха роса зільється страв крило
впереджедума во мні
ямещоо те що шукав славу зу себе переі
те
що
що друзі друзі Хочу зазначити
що наша з вами справа справа захисту
нашої держави дає позитивні
плоди зараз відбувається засідання і
прокурори з'явилися давайте го подуємо
за
це
кожен за те що Вони з'явилися тому що ми
з вами змогли змусити їх
прийтиїх правильно Але ми з вами змогли
ми ми з вами змогли змусити їх
прийти тому зараз хотіла би запросити
пана
Василя голови спілки Чорнобильців в
Василькові будь ласка до
слова Бажаю здоров'я однодумці бажаю
здоров'я воїнам нашим дітям нашим що
вони тут присутні захищають нас від
можна сказати ворога якщо я трошки хочу
сказати про історію України і я як
Ветеран збройних сил України захватив
період радянського часу і захватив
період України 12 років я прослужив в
радянськом союз і 13 років на
Україні 100 років назад будемо говорити
в 17-му році а в 22-му відбувся
Радянський Союз тоді на Скільки
українців було 86 млн скільки на зараз
українців у два рази менше Це що таке Це
говорить про те що ми попали під гніт
Росії Яка зробила голодомор яка виграла
війну радянську Великую вічи няну на
украї на Україні потому що Україна
закрила тілом своїм Росію і не дала
продвинутися на перелі Росії трошки
захотило і Росія знає який воїн
український через що вона хоче до нас
короче нас приєднати до себе тому що
наші воїни будуть захисати руский Мир це
100% і коли у 14-му році почалася війна
України із Росією Хто тут пішов
добровольці пішли розбита армія була Я
це бачив і я це торчув своїй не було ні
одежи Не було нічого два мої сини
захищали Україну один у 15-му році
другий у 17-му році я їх ждав цих синів
і молив Бога щоб вони прийшли додому
прийшов Петро
Порошенко президентом почалось
відновлення Української армії що зараз
робиться закриває вці за ди які люди
хочуть робити нашу техніку хочуть